an 8 MGD water treatment plant has been
designed with six identical rectangular
clarifiers the tanks are installed in
parallel have depths of 10 ft and a
horizontal design velocity of 0.5 ft per
minute if the length to width ratio of
each clarifier is 4:1 how long will the
flow spend in the clarifiers in hours so
this problem doesn't require any
detailed equations from the reference
manual despite the fact that it's about
clarifier design instead we can solve it
using basic flow and geometry so let's
get started for step one we can see that
the design velocity is given in feet per
minute so let's convert our flow to the
same units to convert 8
MGD into cubic feet per minute we can do
the
following we can convert by 1. 547
CFS to
MGD which is a unit conversion you may
find in the front of the reference
manual or have it memorized from there
we can multiply by 60
seconds in 1
minute and that will give us
74256 cubic
feet per minute alternately you could
convert this out longer by converting
million gallons to gallons and days all
the way down to seconds but this is
going to be
faster next we can find the amount of
flow in each
clarifier so this is
straightforward if we have
74256 cubic feet per minute in all of
the
clarifiers
then
we know that we have
12376 cubic feet per minute in each
clarifier for step three we can now find
the area of flow for each
clarifier so let's draw this out so that
you can see what it looks like very
roughly so the velocity passing through
the clarifier is given as
0.5 ft per minute in this
problem and if we look at our Dimensions
we could see that this would be the
depth
D this would
be the width
W and L would be the
length so we we know what the flow is
and we know what the velocity is so
using qal VA we can at least calculate
what the total area of flow should be so
rewriting this to a = q over
V we can see that
123.
76 cubic feet per minute per
clarifier divided by 0
5 ft per
minute will give us
24752 ft
squared per
clarifier so for step
four we can look at the clarifier
dimensions
so the area of flow as we can see from
our drawing over here is going to be the
width times the depth so area equals W *
D and in which case we can see
that
24752 square ft per clarifier
equals 10 ft which was given over here
in the problem as the depth times W so w
solves out to be
ft so now that we have one of the
dimensions we need we can find the rest
in this case the
length so the problem also gives us
the length to width ratio of each
clarifier as being
4:1 so we can say l to
W = 4 to
1 equals some value
to
24.75
Ft so multiplying that by four we would
get an L of just about 99
ft
which finally means all we have to do
now is calculate the
time so time T is going to be given as
the length over the
velocity so if the length is 99 ft
through here at a velocity of
0.5 feet per
minute then the total travel time is
going to take about
198 minutes
or
3.3
hours our answer over here could be the
second one and that'll be all it takes
to solve this problem so the important
thing to recognize here is
that the tanks are in parallel meaning
that they are
designed
side by side and they are not in series
where they'd be passing through each
other one at a time if it had specified
that the tanks were in series we would
need to know the hours spent in one
clarifier and then multiply by the total
number of clarifiers given but in this
case we were given it in parallel so
knowing that is going to be the first
step in solving this problem the rest of
it is just unit conversions
and determining your areas of flow and
then finally solving for the time so
that's
it